I am going to start
off this presentation
with every software engineer's
favorite thing to see,
which is an open GitHub issue.
So the issue that is
on the screen right now
is from the flexdashboard
GitHub page.
And flexdashboard is widely regarded
as one of the easiest ways
to get a Shiny app
dashboard up and running.
Here are the GitHub
users asking how
to make a pretty straightforward
app with a dashboard layout
that appears to be tackling
the seriously troubling issue
of cookie theft.
So the layout is simple.
There's two rows
with a top row having
a tabset on the left and a
terribly troubling plot
with an upward
trajectory on the right.
The bottom is a large panel
that spans the entire width,
and it's terribly
going to be filled
with some very depressing data.
But there are a few
interesting things
about this screenshot that I
want to draw your attention to.
OK is this better?
OK so one of the first things I
want to draw your attention to
is that this issue was opened
in May of 2016, also known
as the before times.
So imagine the devastation
on cookie supplies
that have been wrought
in the six years
that this GitHub
user has been waiting
to build this dashboard.
So next is below, which is
the thumbs up emoji responses.
And there are 18 of them, which
is by far the most up thumbed
issue on this repo.
So clearly other users
have been equally troubled
by burglary of a
confectionery nature.
So why is this issue still open?
If we scroll down,
you can actually
see this is JJ's response,
which is, you can't actually
create this right now.
So at this point, you
might be wondering
why I would dedicate the
first section of my talk
to pointing out the
shortcomings of software
written by the CEO of the
company that I worked for.
And really, I
think it's worth it
because I think it perfectly
encapsulates and motivates
the work that I'm about to show.
So if you went to
Joe's keynote, he
mentioned this in a similar way.
But I really view
Shiny's superpower
as being this force
multiplier, as Joe puts it,
for data scientists to share
their work to a broader
audience.
But really, there's
one kind of hiccup
in that one kind of
hurdle that we've
placed in front of data
scientists in using Shiny.
And to understand what
that is, I kind of
want to start with
a question, which
is what is not crucial to
doing great data science.
You know, there's a
lot of correct answers
to this question, but
the one I'm going for
is understanding the
tangled, terrible web
of getting the browser
to show what you want
and where you want it.
So Shiny does a pretty
decent job of this already.
We have helper functions,
but it could be better.
Like why did this GitHub
issue have to be posted?
Why did this user have trouble
building an app that they
could so clearly draw out?
Shouldn't that be enough
to create your app?
So more concretely, I want to
ask the question of how can we
make constructing the UI of
your Shiny app take less time
and just generally
be more enjoyable?
So we want you,
the data scientist,
to be freed up to do
data science and not
fiddle with your UI code.
And this has really been a
big focus of the Shiny team
for a while now.
And I've been personally working
on it for more than a year
and have come up with two
fairly complementary paths
to try to address this question.
So the first one
is how do we make
declaring your app layout more
straightforward and intuitive?
And the other one is, how do
we provide a new way of writing
the UI code for your app?
So I'm going to start with
the first question, which
is how do we make declaring the
layout of your app a little bit
more intuitive and
straightforward?
So the answer that
we're proposing here
is called grid layout.
So what is grid layout?
First and foremost, grid
layout is an R package
and it provides a
simple interface
for laying out complex
data dashboards.
And also it's built
on a thing called
CSS grid, which is a spec, a CSS
spec built right into your browser.
So there's no external
libraries or JavaScript
that needs to be run to work.
And also because it's
built into your browser,
it's not going to be abandoned.
The project isn't going to
be left and not work later.
So how do we actually go
about using gridlayout?
I'm going to give
you a quick example
in code.
And so we start by using a
gridlayout aware container.
In this case, we're
using grid_page.
We have other containers
for doing like nesting grids
or putting them in
more traditional apps.
But here we're doing
grid_page, which
leaves out your entire
app page with grid layout.
So after that, we
define the layout.
And here this is
the layout defined.
It's a table, but the
table is represented
as a character
vector where there's
two elements in each
element represent
the row of your layout, and
then each column of your layout
is represented as basically
one or more spaces in this one
or more spaces rule allows
you to line things up
like you see here.
So on the top, we have
two columns that say tabs.
Next to that we have cookies
and on the bottom we just
have bottom all the way across.
So then to place items in this
grid, you just use grid_card.
The familiar syntax
kind of like tabsetPanel.
So here like at the
top, we use grid_card
and we place it in the
tabs area of the layout
that we've just defined
using area = "tabs".
We just have to match
each one of those areas
to grid_card or its friends,
such as grid_card_plot.
And this is the output of that
exact code that you just saw.
And it looks pretty similar to
something we've already seen,
which is the layout that
the dashboard GitHub
issue is requesting.
And so this kind of
feels pretty simple,
but really it covers most
of what gridlayout does.
And really gridlayout's
whole goal
is to be this very simple way.
I can think of an app.
I can draw it in a text table.
I can make my app look like that.
OK so that's the first way
that we've tackled this.
How do we make constructing
the UI tiny app more enjoyable?
So let's look at the next way.
And the next way is how can we
provide a new way of writing
the UI code for your app?
And the solution that
we're proposing here
called shinyuieditor.
So the name may give
some of it away.
And also Joe's keynote yesterday
may have given some of it away.
But let's quickly clarify
what the shinyuieditor is.
The shinyuieditor is a
drag-and-drop visual editor
for your Shiny app UI.
So this GIF that
you're seeing kind of
demonstrates that in
pretty concise form.
You can drag elements
around, you can move them,
you can resize them, and it
builds your UI doing that.
And don't worry, we're going
to show a little bit more about
in a few minutes.
The shinyuieditor is
also an R package.
It's not a very
interesting R package.
There's really one function
that you're going to be using,
which is launch editor,
but that's how you get it.
You go just like
any other R package
and store it that way
that you get the shinyuieditor.
So more philosophically,
the shinyuieditor
is an attempt to help you
focus on the fun stuff.
And if you've ever spent a
bunch of time doing things
like tweaking a plot size
or making a column slightly
bigger by incrementing a
pixel value up and testing it,
you kind of know what I mean.
And the UI editor
is really an attempt
to make take that away, let
you just visually drag it
to where you want it to be, and
then let the UI editor write
the code for you.
So now that we've established
kind of what the UI editor is,
let's talk about, I think
just as importantly,
what the UI editor is not.
The UI editor is not
a new UI framework.
It provides like a visual way of
declaring the UI for your app,
but it writes that in
whatever framework you want.
However, we hope that you
really like gridlayout
right now because that's
the only supported layout.
And this is actually kind
of a little historical quirk
that when we started
this whole journey,
we started with grid
layout and then I
made a little visual editor
for editing those tables,
and then it was quickly
realized that there's more here.
Let's expand this.
But right now, you
use the UI editor,
you're also using grid_layout.
But that's going
to change in the future.
So kind of on the
same vein, it's
not going to lock
you into using it.
So by virtue of it just
writing code for you,
if you don't want to use
it, you just stop using it
and you just start
editing your code
like you would edit any
other Shiny app though.
Maybe your app is too complex
for the visual editor and maybe
you just, you know, are using
too many things that are not
supported in it right now.
That's fine.
You're not going to have
to go back to the beginning
and rewrite your app.
And we really put
a fair amount of effort
into making sure that the
code the editor produces
is human readable.
So this is something that has
been really important to us.
And so in a similar
vein, shinyuieditor
is not ready for production,
but it writes code for you.
So, like, in theory, if
that code worked and does
what you want, go for it.
But, you know, it's
still very early.
It's in this alpha stage.
We just haven't had
that many hands on it.
And so we really
are looking forward
to having everybody
get their hands on it.
File issues, you know,
find areas that you would.
You find nice about it and
what you wish it could do.
But don't trust that you're
going to go home after this
and immediately start using
it for your production app.
So shinyuieditor is also
not available for Python.
So you may have noticed that
RStudio now Posit and the Shiny
team have been making inroads
in the Python community,
but the UI editor has not.
So this is just for
Shiny for R right now.
That being said, as both the
UI editor in Shiny for Python
mature, the goal is to
bring it for Python as well.
OK so now that we've kind
of established what it is
and what it isn't, let's
talk about the workflow
of using the UI editor.
So we start by launching the
editor with that function
that we mentioned before,
launch_editor you pointed
at your app location and
this application can exist
or it might not exist.
And if it doesn't exist,
we'll ask you a few questions
and you can start with template
app that UI editor friendly.
Once you've done that, the
UI editor spins up a browser
window, you can use the visual
interface to edit your app code
and then you close your browser
window and you enjoy the app.
Optionally, you can
rinse and repeat,
and I think that this
is really important.
We're not setting
this UI editor up
to be a way that
you start your app
and then you go on to
never using it again.
It can ingest apps that it wrote
ingest app that in theory it didn't
write, and then so you can
have it kind of carry you
through your whole Shiny
app development process.
Maybe later on you
need to add a new plot.
You can do that
with the UI editor,
not just the way of setting up.
That's all good and
interesting to hear
a bunch of tech
snippets and me read
about what the UI editor is,
but it's the visual tool.
I think it's probably
valuable to actually see
what it looks like.
So I was going to do a live
demo, but I was told, Oh.
Well there we go.
OK never say.
So we're going to start here.
Let me talk quick.
So we have a fresh
RStudio project open.
There's nothing in it can
see in the files pane.
It's pretty small.
I apologize for that.
But there's nothing
sitting in there.
And so we've run this
launch editor function
and pointed it to the
current app directory
and it says we
can't find an app.
So we fill out
some template that
says, yeah, we want to create
a new app from a template.
And so we say, yes,
we do, and then it
asks us what template we want.
So we have a couple of
templates right now.
Rewind this.
A couple of templates.
So there's geyser
templates and then
there's this chick
weights template.
And I don't know about you
guys, but my very first job
was actually as a
chicken farmer before I
had this cushy
software developer job.
And so I was not a park
Ranger at Yellowstone.
So I'm not going to
use the geyser app.
I'm going to do chick weights.
I've seen enough geysers thing.
So we choose that way.
It spins up the UI editor
and this is what we have.
And so this is in a browser tab.
And so looking at
what we have here,
we start we have this
element panel on the left.
You can drag and drop elements
from that into your app.
Then in the middle, there's
this kind of app pane.
It's the skeleton.
It's not exactly your app.
We have faux plots
there, and on the right
we have a properties panel.
This properties panel
tells you things
like where the element
is within your UI tree
and then you also
have an app preview.
So that App Main window
that you saw isn't perfect.
So if you really need to
see what your app like.
And so we have to plots
on top of each other here,
and maybe we want to put those
plots next to each other.
So we can do that.
Just by reaching up and
adding a new column,
we can drag one of the plots
over and drag one of the plots
up.
Now we have this whole
empty row on the bottom.
We can just delete that.
So we could check to make
sure that work and our app
is updated instantly to
build that new layout.
And so from there we
might say, you know,
let's maybe let's shrink
this column on the left
and emphasize the
line plots on the right.
Do that and it automatically
updates.
And so one of the things
we might want to do also
is right now, the
number of lines
that are shown in that plot
is given via numeric input.
But maybe we want
to use a slider
so we can delete that element.
We can drag a slider input
in, go to the input ID,
change it to the numCh icks,
which is what
that reactive input is set as.
And then we can go
and change the value.
So we're going to
say Min 1, Max 20 and
we're going to use step
size of 1.
And then we can change the
label to say number of chicks.
Then we can go back to the app
preview to see if that worked.
And we can drag it and see yep,
The app is actively
updated and it is working.
This kind of workflow
of going back and forth
between the preview
and the editor
is what we envisioned
people doing.
The next, we might want
to change the title.
So it's this Chick
Weights right now.
Let's change it to
RStudio Conf 2022
and we'll left align
it so we can
see in the little tiny preview
on the bottom that it updated.
But I want to emphasize
another point, which
is the fact that you can
edit the code as well.
So we go into the app
code that the UI editor
generated for us previously
there was nothing there.
And what we see we can
find this RStudio Conf 2022
and let's change that
right in the code,
make it Posit::Conf and 2022
but make sure it's an integer
so we'll add an L. Then we
save that and we go back and
the UI editor is
automatically updated.
And so this is
really emphasizing
that we have this workflow of
some things might be easier
to do in the UI editor and
to do in code.
And we don't want
to hold you back.
We want the UI editor
to just sit there.
Maybe you just want to use
it to resize columns or add
a new plot, but you want to
type your contents or whatever
by hand.
There's no, you can
go back and forth
between the code and the UI.
Edit or leave it up and just
edit your app as you go.
And so we can just check
now to make sure that worked.
So we can open up the
app that it generated,
the app that it generated.
And so it worked... Good.
Given that I pre-recorded
this demo, that would be
pretty bad if it didn't work.
OK so.
OK so quickly, I just want
to talk about the philosophy
of the UI editor.
So one thing that you might
be asking at this point
is how do we avoid some of
the common pitfalls of no code
solution?
Because the UI editor is, in
a way, a no code solution.
And this is something
that we were very
careful about when we started.
And I think the simplest
answer to that is
that it's not a no code editor.
We're fundamentally
writing code.
The UI editor is a
visual interface,
but everything goes immediately
back to code and vice versa.
And so really, I don't
think of it as no code.
I really think of it is
like a fancy autocomplete,
you know, you might be able
to tab complete something
and it does what you want.
This is essentially
doing that for your UI.
And so we also really
tried to keep it as simple
as we possibly could, because
one of the things that
happens with no code
editors is that code
is an extremely wonderful
medium for expressing yourself.
RStudio is really a
proponent of the power of code.
And so the problem with
that extreme flexibility
is that there's a
lot of solution space
that you need to make
available if you really
want to fully explore that.
And so visibly mapping to that
space can be really intense.
So we really carefully pulled
everything back to make sure
that we just let you
edit your UI code.
You can move things, you
can set some settings.
We're really not trying to go
crazy and let you do everything
because we found that in a
lot of tools that do that, you
actually might as well just
learn how to code instead
of some esoteric visual
editor, because at least then
you know how to code.
Don't have some skill that's
not going to work anywhere else.
And so I think the last and
most important part about it
is that this is the Shiny UI Editor
and that's an important fact.
It's the UI Editor it's
not the Shiny app.
We're not trying to
write your server code.
We want you to write that.
I think that you're the
best person to do that.
We want you to, as
the data scientist,
to write your cool plots
and your good models
and all that stuff.
We're just going to make it
a little bit easier for you
to build the UI if we don't want
you to have to be an expert web
developer to create a nice
looking layout for your app.
So the UI editor is the UI
editor, not the server editor.
It's not a full
no code solution.
That being said, there
are solutions out there
that are full no code that
write the server code for you.
And there's actually
talk coming up after this
that I'm pretty excited
to see those just that.
That's all of the slides I have.
This is links.
So if you scan
this QR code, it'll
take you to a Quarto site that
has links for the website
and the GitHub for both grid
layout and the Shiny UI editor.
Some info on these slides
and some of my links.
I just pushed them all live just
before this so they don't work.
I'm sorry, but they should work.
And that is all I have for you.
Thank you so much.